[MUSIC PLAYING]
BRAHIM ELBOUCHIKHI:
Good morning, everyone.
How are you feeling?
Woo!
This sweatshirt is made
out of 20 Daydream Views.
No, I'm kidding,
I just bought it.
Let's get started.
My name is Brahim
Elbouchikhi, and I'm
a product manager on
the platform team,
on the Daydream platform team.
We have two goals for this talk.
The first is to share a
bunch of data and insights
we have learned from being in
market for the last six months
we think it's important
that as the VR industry gets
started, that we share as much
as we can with the broader
community.
The second goal is to
walk you through how
we're taking those
insights and that data
and applying it to
the Daydream platform
itself to make it work better
for developers and for users.
So let's get started.
First is a bunch of updates.
These are recaps you've
heard probably already.
First, we now have eight
Daydream-ready phones.
If you recall, last
year in November
we launched with support
for the Pixel the Pixel XL.
But our mission has
always been about bringing
high-quality mobile
VR to everyone.
So we've been hard
at work to bring
in more devices that
support Daydream.
We're also particularly
excited about the fact
that the Samsung S8 will also
be Daydream ready in the coming
weeks.
Also LG's flagship device that
is available later this summer
will also be Daydream ready.
And finally, our
existing partners Asus
and Motorola will also be
bringing in more Daydream-ready
devices to market.
So putting all that together, as
Mike summarized in the morning,
we'll have tens of millions
of Daydream-ready devices
in market.
Those devices, when paired
with one of the headsets,
allow you to
experience Daydream.
So that's a great
user base for you
all to target with your content.
The other big news,
obviously, of I/O
is the introduction of
the standalone VR headset.
Darren is going to
get onstage in a bit
and tell you a lot more about
the headsets and how they work
and other things.
But the one thing
I want to highlight
is that the standalone
headsets get
at the same mission of
the smartphones, which
is bringing high-quality
mobile VR to everyone.
In this case, if you don't
own an Android device,
this may be an option.
Another option is maybe
a different user journey
where you have a
shared device that's
available at home that's always
connected to power, and also
to Wi-Fi.
That way you can
jump into VR anytime.
So Darren will get
into more details,
but we're super excited about
this development, obviously.
Finally, at the end
of the day, users
purchase these headsets
to experience the content
that developers create.
And we're excited that
since January, we're
more than tripled the number
of apps available on Daydream
to 150.
It's exciting, and we expect
to see an increase in momentum
over the coming
months as we roll out
more of the experiences that are
being developed at the moment.
So that's great news.
So we'll share five
insights with you.
These are data-driven
insights that we
hope you will find useful as
you create your VR content.
First, this is Daydream
Home in its current form.
Again, Darren will get
onstage and tell you
about how it will be
changed in the future.
But in the current form, we have
those three panels at the top.
We call them Discovery Windows.
These panels are used to
feature specific content.
These are deep links
to videos, to apps,
and specific
experiences in an app.
We use them to feature
content for users.
So keep that in mind as
I share the data next.
First, 25% of
sessions on Daydream
begin with no specific intent.
And if you think
about that, if you
think about your
smartphone, how often do
you turn on your smartphone
with absolutely no intent?
Not to check time,
not to check email,
not to check
Twitter, not to play
a game, not to do other things.
And so in smartphones, we've
become very task centric.
There's a specific thing you're
trying to do with the phone,
and you're going to
go there to do that.
This is quite different.
Lots of users coming
with no intent.
The next data point is
that 40% of all sessions
include at least one click
on a Discovery Window.
Which, benchmarking against
traditional merchandising-type
experiences, is
actually quite good.
Finally, 35% of all
sessions include
a visit to Play Store VR.
If you put these three
data points together,
our takeaway is that
on VR, in VR, users
are in discovery mode.
They're open minded.
They're coming in and
saying, what's awesome in VR?
What can I do today?
What can I experience
today in Daydream?
And that's great news because
it creates an opportunity
for developers to
fill that need,
to create great content
that people love
and use and purchase.
Which is obviously essential.
I was on Android market in 2011.
And at that time, high-quality
apps got a lot of traffic,
a lot of users, a
lot of attention.
And we see it in a similar
state at this point in VR.
And so the insight we're
trying to share with you today,
as a developer,
this may be the time
to get involved, start
experimenting, start
iterating so they can build
the Angry Birds for VR.
Angry Birds standing in
for the breakout hit.
So if you remember in 2009
when Angry Birds came out,
it was one of the first titles
where everything came together
just perfectly.
The game mechanic used
a screen a unique way.
The characters
were really great,
the branding, the
monetization model worked.
Everything worked
really well, but that
wasn't an overnight success.
It took a lot of iteration.
It took a lot of work
to actually get there.
And so we firmly believe
that developers on Daydream
today are converging
on that breakout hit.
Learning, iterating,
and getting closer
to creating this breakout hit.
So if you've been as a
developer thinking about VR,
considering whether to
get involved or not,
I would urge you to look
closer and consider actually
doing that.
So next, I'm going to show
you a video from a title that
just became
available on Daydream
called Lola and the Giant.
It's built by Climax Studios.
And what's awesome with
this title is, one,
the environment
is super awesome.
It's really
immersive, it's great.
And there are two characters.
There's a giant who
you actually can
take the perspective of
the giant in the game,
and you can have
different skill sets,
and it's literally like a giant.
And then you can also be
a third-person follower
along with Lola as she conquers
all sorts of challenges
and does all sorts of fun stuff.
Interestingly also, there is
a companion experience where
outside of VR--
there you go, the
video is playing--
where outside of VR, a user
can also interact in the game.
It means you can have this
asymmetric game experience
where one person is in
2D, the other is in VR,
and they're able to
collaborate together.
We think that's
really fun, and we
think this is a title that's
getting at that breakout hit.
We feel it's a title that's
trying different things,
innovating in the space,
and really getting
at something awesome.
So if you haven't tried
it, it just came out.
It's super awesome.
Please do.
Now, let's talk
about monetization.
That's obviously a big part
of this, a big part of helping
you earn a living on Daydream.
And so a couple of
data points I want
to share with you is
that on Daydream, we've
seen three times as
many buyers as you
would on traditional
mobile, on Google Play.
And those buyers are
spending 32% more
than they would on
traditional mobile.
This is good news, right?
Because creating VR
content is expensive.
It's hard.
It takes a lot of time.
And the fact that users
are responding well,
they're willing to
purchase the content,
and also they're
actually spending
more on it, that's really
good news for our developer
community and for our platform.
However, we talk
to our users a lot.
We do a lot of user studies.
We talk with them a lot.
And in almost every
single one, we've
heard feedback that if we had
a way, if users had a way,
to try and experience
before buying it,
that would help them make
that purchase decision more
frequently.
And so the insight here is
actually more often ask, most
for request, if you have an
experience on Daydream today,
if it is premium, i.e., like
you've got to pay upfront,
consider ways to actually
introduce a trial to it.
It is not easy.
There is no single
way to do this, right?
It depends by title,
it depends by user,
it depends by developing
your goals for your title,
so it's not easy.
But we believe that
this isn't something
that's going to go away.
The need for trying an
experience is fundamental to VR
because it's an
immersive technology.
I've got to be in it to
actually know what it's about.
There are also
physiological differences
that make it so one title
that's comfortable for one user
may not be as comfortable
for someone else.
So they need just makes sense.
We're doing our best
to figure this out.
And as soon as we
do, we'll, as usual,
communicate our findings.
But as developers,
iterating and experimenting
in this direction.
How do you get your
users to experiment
and try your content
first is actually
going to be key
to, again, get into
that successful monetization,
successful breakout hit.
Now let's talk about
usage patterns.
What we've seen on
Daydream is that users
are spending on average about
40 minutes a week in VR.
What's unique is that this is
spent in a couple of sessions
only, in the evenings at
home, or on the weekends.
And if today you are a
developer of a 2D game or app,
it's quite different from
what you're seeing, right?
What you're seeing
today is a lot
of interactions, a lot
of micro sessions of 30
seconds to a minute
to a couple of minutes
maybe where you are
getting users coming back.
They are either collecting
energy or points or something,
and then going back out again.
That's different in VR.
And so the way we've been
kind of summarizing this now
for a while is that as
you build content for VR,
think of a sit-down meal
experience, not a snack.
It's not something that people
are doing throughout the day.
Its fewer, longer sessions.
Next, I want to show you a video
from the Gorillaz latest album.
This was created
in collaboration
with Google Spotlight Stories.
And was awesome about
this-- you're actually
in a train track.
It's moving super fast, you feel
literally like you're there,
and you can look around.
There are different characters,
the Gorillaz behind you,
and you're actually
listening to the music.
And there's also a
tablet showing you
what would probably look like
a traditional music video.
And what's awesome about
this medium of VR video
is that not only are you
listening to the artist's
creation as a song.
You're also experiencing
the environment
they wanted you to be in
when you listen to it.
It just works really well.
If you haven't tried
this, it's actually
got 3 million views in 48 hours,
making it the biggest debut
of a VR video on YouTube ever.
It was super awesome, give
it a try if you haven't yet.
And so the takeaway here,
and the fact, actually,
is that nearly 50% of
all time in Daydream
is spent in video experiences.
This is split
across flat content.
This is traditional
2D content that's
projected in a personal
cinema, as we like to call it,
from Netflix, Hulu, Play Movies,
HBO, and also immersive 360 VR
video that's created by our
partners, our Baobab, and WeVR,
and NextVR, and
Within, and many others
who have created
truly awesome videos.
A lot of them are
documentaries that
allows you to really be
immersed in the story
and feel probably, to be
honest, as much about how
that person, that documentary,
feel as ever before in media.
So the insight here is
that video is really
a core use case of mobile VR.
It is a core use case.
And so as a developer,
as a creator,
think about ways to use it
to augment your experience,
to create an experience
that's great.
So for example, as we
talked about trials, maybe
VR video is a way
to offer that trial.
And finally, I want to share
another data point with you
about quality.
This chart shows a
correlation between time
in an app and the app's rating.
Of course, it's a
positive correlation.
The significance is
actually quite high.
But what's important here is
we purposely chose time in app,
not installs, which is
how you traditionally
look at operations.
And you say if I have a higher
rating, I get more installs,
and that's great.
But here, we wanted to
show engagement in use,
and the impact of having
a great quality app.
Now, keep in mind that Daydream
has a fairly stringent quality
review process.
So these apps aren't
like, crashing,
or have low frames per
second, or other things.
The difference here
is actually almost
thinking from good to great,
not so much kind of very poor.
And the differences being the
immersiveness of the content,
the depth of the
content, the environment
and the beauty of it.
And so as you build
content for VR,
think about quality,
but not only
in terms of technical quality.
Also in the depth
of the experience,
and just how awesome it is.
So to summarize, now
is the time for you
as a developer to jump in and
potentially create VR's Angry
Birds.
It will take time, and those
developers creating today
are iterating and
approaching that milestone.
Trials are fundamental parts
of VR content creation,
and they will help unlock the
full potential of monetization.
So you need to think
about those from day one.
In terms of content
duration and length,
think about a sit-down
meal experience.
Think about how
you could use video
to augment your experience.
And finally, quality in VR goes
beyond the technical aspects
and into depth of
the content, and just
how immersive the experience is.
So that's all.
I'm going to turn
over to Darren now,
who will show you how we're
taking these insights and more
and improving the
Daydream experience
for you and for our users.
Thank you.
DARREN DELAYE: All
right, thanks, Brahim.
Hi, everyone.
I'm Darren Delaye, and I lead
the user experience design
team for the Daydream platform.
And today, I get to tell you
more about some of the design
work my team has been doing,
how we think about designing
the experience for our
standalone VR headsets,
and some of the
improvements that we're
making for Daydream platform 2.0
Euphrates, which is the release
later this year.
This week, we've announced
Daydream standalone headsets
with WorldSense positional
tracking, an all-new form
factor for VR.
And I'm going to break
this down into some pieces.
First, let's talk
about what it means
to have a standalone headset.
A standalone headset
purpose built for VR
brings a new level
of convenience
to how you access VR.
When it's on your counter
or your coffee table
and you can pick it up and in
just a few seconds be in VR,
I think you'll find that
you and the other members
of your household will end up
going into VR a lot more often.
Lowering the friction to go
into VR makes a big difference.
From a developer
perspective, you
use the same exact
developer tools and SDKs
as you do for smartphone VR.
And in most cases,
you'll create apps
that run on both smartphone
VR and standalone VR headsets.
Existing Daydream apps
like these are all
compatible with the
standalone headsets.
And for interacting
with VR apps,
you'll still be using the
Daydream motion controller
to point and swing and play.
Now, since there
isn't a phone mode,
setup and settings are all
done from inside the headset.
These will be some of
the very first VR systems
where there isn't a phone or a
PC as the primary setup device.
And what I want to mention
here is that the same
goes for app developers.
There are some great examples
of what we call hybrid 2D and 3D
apps for Daydream.
For example, the app named
Within has a great phone
mode where you can look at
a preview of all the videos
they've released.
And if you want to check
one out, click on it
and hop into VR.
So just keep in mind that
since your standalone headset
users will only
have VR, you need
to make sure that important
required features like account
sign in or settings are
accessible from your game
engine VR mode.
All right, now let's talk about
WorldSense positional tracking.
We get full six degrees
of freedom tracking,
or 6DoF tracking, that works
with no external wires,
sensors, or setup.
It just works.
It's based on technology
from the Tango team
that tracks objects in real time
as they move about in 3D space.
So instead of just
being able to know
the orientation of the
headset, where you're looking,
now we're going to be able to
track the movement of your head
as well in any direction.
Now, these WorldSense
headsets are
optimized for seated and
standing virtual reality.
It allows you to naturally
move, lean, shift
your weight and body
position however you want.
Positional tracking creates
a much more immersive VR
experience.
Everything feels more real.
And in turn, that makes the
experience more comfortable.
The realism comes in large part
from your natural perception
of all the tiny
movements that your head
is making all the
time that create
parallax between foreground
and background elements.
The same thing happens
in the real world
when you perceive the
world all day, every day.
Here's a quick example of
a dodge ball game demo.
You can duck and
dodge out of the way.
I lean out of the way every
time I watch this video.
[LAUGHING]
BRAHIM ELBOUCHIKHI: Sorry.
DARREN DELAYE: If
you want to create
an experience that requires
ducking and dodging
and leaning, you can.
You can target our
WorldSense headsets.
Now, we do want to make
sure that people stay safe
in their physical space.
Most people don't
have a lot of space.
And even if you clear
an area in your room,
we want to help people avoid
bumping into their furniture
and their walls.
We have a basic
safety system in place
that encourages people to
stay roughly in one spot
and not walk around,
not wander too far
from where they set as the
center of their experience.
Remember, this is
mobile VR, so you
can start your experience
anywhere in the room,
or really anywhere.
And we have a sensor
that actually detects
when you put the headset
on and where you are,
which lets us set that is
the default starting position
with the VR world
centered around you.
Now I'm going to give you
a couple of quick things
to think about if
you're creating
apps and games for our
Daydream WorldSense headsets.
Here's one thing that
works really well.
The scenes with
relatively small items
that are pretty close up
when you move back and forth
from side to side, although
you don't want anything
closer than about half a meter
from your face for too long.
If you think about something
like a board game on a table,
or a game where you feel really
big because all the characters
are really small,
those are going
to feel really good when
you shift your weight
and get a large amount of
parallax from small movements.
For example, you'll be able
to see around one character
to see the character behind.
In this example from
the game Mekorama,
there's the user
peeking from side
to side to plan out how they're
going to solve the puzzle.
But here's an example
where you may have
to design around the parallax.
In this pointer-based
interface, something
that we use frequently
in Daydream,
when the user hovers
their cursor over an item,
we usually bring it towards them
a bit, and it looks like this.
You're highlighting
the item in upper left.
So here's what it might look
like if this UI is pretty
close up to the user, and
they've moved or leaned
over to the right.
It's not pointing
at them anymore.
They're kind of looking
at it from a side angle.
And you might decide that
this isn't what you want.
There are lots of ways
to design around this.
You might decide that
you want to turn the UI.
But one that I want
to mention quickly
is you can make everything
look roughly the same
and move the UI farther
back from the user.
And you'll have to scale
up the cards and the text
to compensate to make
it still legible.
And if you move the
UI farther away,
then when the user makes
that same amount of movement
over to the right, they're
going to see a smaller
amount of parallax,
and it's going
to look more similar to how
it does from straight on.
So if you want to learn more
about how my team specifies
designs like this, how we
create legible and usable UIs,
we have a great talk
tomorrow about designing
screen interfaces for VR that
I think you should check out.
Now, if you want
your users to be
able to move over
greater distances in VR,
our favorite method is to
have people teleport from spot
to spot.
And this is a pattern that a lot
of apps have adopted already.
This is what we've found most
effective in all types of VR,
from smartphone VR to
positionally tracked systems.
In fact, we've noticed that
once you give people the ability
to teleport, they
actually stop their urge
to walk around, and just
teleport all around.
And they start
intuitively using it,
and they end up staying
safer and not needing
as big of a physical space.
So we're big fans of
teleporting around in VR.
And we're releasing a new set
of sample code as something
that we call Daydream
Elements, which
has an implementation
of teleporting that you
can use to get you started.
This recording is from the
Daydream Elements sample app.
Now we're going to switch
over and talk about features
in the Daydream 2.0
Euphrates release that's
coming out later this year.
These are features coming to
all headsets, both smartphone VR
and standalone VR.
Here's a preview of our
updated Daydream Home.
We've had users
tell us the Daydream
Home is simple and
approachable, and we
plan to keep it that way.
We'll swipe through these.
So the changes we've
made are mostly related
to the Discovery Windows
that you see in the middle.
Now there are more
of them, and they're
organized into collections.
Some collections
are for new users
with the all-time best content
that nobody should miss.
Other collections
are for people who
are watching this
space frequently
for newly released
content and new releases.
And other collections
are on a trend or a theme
that people are gravitating
to when they come to Daydream.
All these Discovery
Windows feature
all kinds of content,
apps and games,
as well as individual
experiences in videos.
They're actually under
the hood Android Intents
that we deep link to.
So if you're
creating an app that
has individual experiences,
make sure to plan
for those incoming links.
Our goal was Daydream
Home is that people
will come to VR frequently,
and they'll never run out
of new things to experience.
The next feature is what we
call the system dashboard.
The motivation for this
is that sometimes you're
in the middle of
a VR experience,
and you wonder if
there's something
that needs your attention.
Or you just need
to check the time.
We want to enable these things
without a jarring interruption
to your experience.
So when the user presses
the System button,
the system dashboard
will pop up.
And when they press the
System button again,
it will disappear and
return them right back
into what they were doing.
Users can check on status
like time and battery life,
they can activate
system features like Do
Not Disturb Mode
or Casting, which
I'll talk more
about in a moment,
or they can quickly launch the
next step they want to open.
They also check
their notifications,
which can give them peace
of mind about whether they
have more time to stay in VR.
In Daydream 1.0,
there were a couple
of scenarios when you may have
had to take your phone out
of the headset and complete
a task in phone mode
before you could continue.
That would be like if
YouTube, in this example,
needed to have access
to the microphone,
and needed to ask for
permission so that you
could do a voice search.
Or if you needed to update your
credit card expiration date
to make a purchase of a game.
Well, we're bringing
those experiences into VR
so that you can complete these
required tasks quickly and get
back to what you want to do.
If you think about
it, this was something
that we had to do for
our standalone headsets.
And it's a nice improvement
for smartphone VR as well.
Stepping back, I think that
one of our most important roles
here at Daydream is
to try to make sure
that VR fits into your
life, not just something
that you do by yourself.
And so my favorite feature
that we're announcing today
is Casting.
I bet many of you here have
given VR demos to your friends,
and it's great to see
their reactions to new VR
experiences.
But it's not so great if
they get a little bit stuck,
or they ask you
what to click on,
but you can't see
what's happening.
Or sometimes there will
be one person in VR
and other people just
waiting their turn.
So with Casting, we
can bridge the gap.
You can share the experience
with a whole group.
And here's our animation
of how it works.
In the system dashboard, you
choose the cast receiver,
and it starts playing
on your TV right away.
And casts work across apps.
So you can start a session
and pass the headset
to multiple people,
check out multiple apps,
with the cast running
the whole time.
We think this is going to make
mobile VR that much more fun
in your living room.
For developers, if you
want to get a little fancy,
there are some interesting
gameplay mechanics
that you could consider
implementing using Casting.
In this example, prototypers
from our Daydream Labs team
have created essentially
acting out a puppet show
where the person
in the headset is
giving a tour of the spaceship.
And the people
watching on the TV
have a fixed camera position.
You have to have enough
performance overhead
available for your app
to be able to render
this extra camera.
So it's a little
bit challenging.
But there are really
interesting things.
Like, for example,
you could be playing
a guessing game, a party
game, where there's something
that the person in the
headset is supposed to know
but not the people in the room.
Or the opposite, that there
is something that the people
in the room should see that
the person in the headset
shouldn't.
And for times where you're
not in the same room
as your friends,
we're also announcing
support for VR Captures,
both screenshots
and video recordings, which
will save your device.
And you can sync
with Google Photos
and share them however you want.
We use our smartphone cameras
in the real world every day,
and this is the start of
being able to record and share
the best things that you
encounter in VR as well.
So find out more at
developers.google.com/vr,
which we've added one of my
favorite new tools for Daydream
developers, which
is instant preview,
which makes iterating in
Unity and Unreal much faster
by letting you play a
live preview directly onto
your Daydream View.
And here are the
upcoming Daydream talks
that I encourage you to attend.
Three more today, and one
tomorrow from our design team.
So thank you very much.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]